[Music]
welcome back everyone so i'm really
excited to continue this lecture series
on reinforcement learning and in this
one i'm going to zoom in specifically on
deep rl deep reinforcement learning or
set another way reinforcement learning
using deep neural networks okay this is
one of the most exciting trends uh both
in control theory and in machine
learning over the past decade uh and
there's just a ton of new and exciting
results out every month uh it seems on
deep reinforcement learning
just a reminder this is um
following roughly a new chapter in the
second edition of our data driven
science and engineering book so i wrote
a reinforcement learning chapter to cap
off that
control theory part
it was also a great excuse for me to
learn
more about reinforcement learning so
that's something actually just a meta
point for for all of you
uh you know trying to explain things to
people is always the best way to learn
something
and this was really you know i took this
as an excuse to
i wanted to learn about reinforcement
learning so i wrote a book chapter and
made this this video sequence
um so i hope you are also enjoying it as
much as i am
okay so this is such a big field i am
going to touch on the you know the tip
of the iceberg of all of the different
techniques of deep reinforcement
learning
and i actually have another video
from you know a number of months ago
maybe even a year ago where i talked at
a very high level about how you can use
deep
neural networks and reinforcement
learning
and i mostly did this with examples and
demonstrations of all the cool stuff you
can do
so today i'm going to dig deeper into
more of the algorithms and how these
different flavors of deep reinforcement
learning fit into kind of our classic
our classic pictures that we've been
developing over the last few lectures
okay i'm going to jump right in and
hopefully this one's kind of exciting
all right so the first type of of kind
of deep neural network uh embedded into
a reinforcement learner kind of the
simplest thing you can do
is what's called a deep policy network
so your policy function pi
is presumably a relatively complex
function of the state
uh the state you find yourself in s and
the action you're going to take a so
it's the probability of taking an action
given that you're currently in state a
and this is supposed to be optimized to
maximize uh future rewards in your
system okay
so this policy pie could be pretty
complicated it could have there could be
a lot of rules or you know physics of
how you make decisions and actions
optimally given the state that you find
yourself in
i don't know why i have a terminator
here but presumably it's using a deep
neural network uh to optimize its policy
and so that policy function pi
can be parametrized as a neural network
with uh weights theta so the input of
the neural network is the state the
output is some probability of which
action to take and you may you know flip
a coin and take an action based on that
probability
and so what we would be trying to do is
to optimize
uh over these parameters theta to
maximize the future reward to give
myself the best policy pi possible
okay so there is a brilliant
blog by andre carpathy deep
reinforcement learning pong from pixels
where they essentially
walk through and they actually provide a
python code with about 150 lines of code
that actually codes up this deep policy
network so it's really really cool
basically how you would take a high
dimensional state s this is a high
dimensional measurement of your system
this is pixel space so
you know there
are over a thousand pixels in this image
that are input into this policy network
and then essentially the policy network
is optimized to make the best decision
of whether or not i should move up or
down my my pong paddle okay so you're
this character on the right and all that
you have to do is based on the current
pixels decide what's the probability of
moving up or down and then take an
action based on that probability
and so the idea here is at a very very
high level
is that we have our policy parametrized
by the network weights theta
and we're going to optimize over theta
to give us the best chance of getting a
future reward
and i'm being a little bit intentionally
vague about you know i'm not writing
down a loss function a neural network
loss function that we're training over
because there are different ways that
you can optimize using these deep policy
networks and actually one of the uh the
easiest ways
essentially you can use back propagation
so you know neural network training in
general uses this this idea of back
propagation so information kind of
upstream can be propagated back and
eventually used to compute gradients and
optimize these these weights
and so the basic idea is that i would
optimize my weights by computing
gradients based on this cumulative
expected future reward
and so this is partly why i'm being
vague
is you have a lot of choices on how to
represent this future reward
so if you represent that that cumulative
future reward using a value network so
if you have a policy network to make
actions to take decision to make
decisions on what actions to take
and you are estimating your future
reward using a value network that would
be an actor critic network
so there's different ways of kind of
embedding information into this this
deep policy network but the basic idea
is that you you represent your policy as
a network and you optimize over its
parameters using essentially gradients
through
gradients of something through back
propagation
i'm going to talk more about this
okay um
this is an aside that i think is really
important and i want to tell you about
but if you don't love you know math
derivations you can skip these next five
minutes
this is kind of the guts of how policy
gradient optimization works in general
this is this is more general than neural
networks
if you have a policy function
pi that is parametrized by some
parameters theta this could be a support
vector machine this could be some other
kind of model or it could be a neural
network
where the weights are parametrized by
theta
then i am essentially going to derive
how
if you take the chain rule
or if you take the gradient of this this
reward function this cumulative reward
function you can get a signal to update
your policy weights data so again if you
don't love math you can skip this next
five minutes but i think this is kind of
important
okay so the cumulative future reward r
sigma given a set of parameters theta
for my policy so you can think of theta
as being a policy if you like
is the following so mu sub theta
is the uh kind of expected future
distribution or probability of finding
yourself in a state s at long times
given this policy theta
so it's kind of the asymptotic
distribution if you played this game for
a long time this would be the expected
probability of finding yourself in any
of those states s out of all possible
states so this is a probability
distribution of where you find yourself
in long times this is kind of just to be
mathematically precise we need this part
here
and we would add so uh so we wait by the
the probability of finding yourself in a
state in long time
and then you weight by
the quality function the quality of
being in that state
okay and and taking that action
times the probability of taking that
action given your weights theta
this is a bit of a complicated
expression this is you can kind of
convince yourself that this is true and
this is outlined in detail in the
chapter in the book
that this is consistent
with
how we normally write
this reward function
as the sum of all the future possible
rewards
this is just folding it up using this
quality function okay so it's the
quality of being in a state and an
action so i have to add up over all of
the probabilities of being in taking any
of those actions
so you can this is a sum or a weighted
sum over actions and similarly i have to
do that same weighted sum over states
and i'm using the asymptotic
probability of being in that state
so this is the the cumulative future
reward
and what you'll notice is that we now we
don't have the policy anywhere we just
sorry we do have the policy but it's
parameterized by theta
so essentially what we can do is take uh
the gradient of this reward with respect
to theta
because that's the signal we're going to
use to change or to update theta we're
going to use gradient optimization
presumably using back propagation in
neural networks
so we need to compute this this gradient
we want to move in the direction that in
theta that increases r
we want to move in the direction of
theta that increases the total reward
and so if i take
the the chain rule here or just
basically propagate this this derivative
through you'll notice that
this term here
is a function of theta and so i compute
its its gradient with respect to theta
and the next step is really just uh
keeping track of of algebra here so what
i've done is i've taken this expression
here and i divide by the policy theta
and so i multiply by the policy pi theta
on the left so these cancel each other
out i'm just you know dividing by it
over here multiplying it by it over here
so nothing changed
now i'm asking myself this question and
i hope you're asking the same question
why didn't
my mu sub theta why didn't i have to
chain rule this
this object here
and that's a really good question
i'm going to have to think about that
and
maybe you can comment below in the in
the video and we can work through uh
kind of what went wrong here but this is
this is just a sketch of how we can get
uh this policy gradient information okay
so so you do this
and now you'll notice uh that this term
here is just the gradient of the
logarithm of my policy the gradient of
the logarithm
so now we have pi my policy times the q
function so everything to the left here
is the reward is the reward that i had
times the gradient of the log of the
policy with respect to theta
and so now this is the expected value of
my quality function
times the gradient of the log of my
policy with respect to theta
and so this can be used essentially as
the the signal this i can compute
uh so so essentially i can compute the
log of my my uh probability
pi
and i can weight it by my
quality function and that gives me the
information i need to update my my
weights theta so i just need to compute
this
using
back propagation and this is better
conditioned to compute with okay again
this is a bit of a mathematical aside
but uh if you're interested for example
you know in how you actually compute
this uh this policy gradient this is at
least one way that you would do that
okay good so this is where i really
wanted to get to is deep cue learning so
most of the most impressive
demonstrations of deep reinforcement
learning at least in the last five or
ten years
many of them have been deep q learning
where essentially you learn a quality
function
with a neural network
so again
we know this is the basic formula for q
learning it is a
off policy temporal difference learning
algorithm so this is my estimated i'm
sorry this is my estimate of my future
reward if i'm at state s now and i take
action a now
and this is my actual reward if i take
that action and i actually get a reward
this is the actual future reward
and so the error signal between these i
can use to update my quality function as
i learn through trial and error so we've
already had a whole lecture on this
and so essentially what you can do is
you can parametrize this quality
function by some neural network weights
theta
and this is really really useful because
if you think about the kinds of things
we use q learning for or deep q learning
for
the state space s might be
astronomically big for example if i'm
playing a game of backgammon or chess or
go
the number of board combinations in
chess is more than 10 to the 80. it's
more than there are nucleons in the in
the known universe and go has an even
larger state space s
so instead of you know iterating over
states over and over
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
parametrize this quality function by a
much much lower dimensional set of
parameters theta and then optimize over
theta
so essentially you can think of this as
as extracting features kind of low
dimensional features of your quality
function that are parametrized by
theta or you know some neural network
and we're going to optimize theta to get
a better q function
and this is going to really really be
important to address the curse of
dimensionality we have in these very
high dimensional state spaces
and so with this one i actually will
write down the actual cost function uh
involved in solving this uh this so this
is the neural network cost function
that we use when we uh when we build a
deep q learner
essentially the loss function that the
the network is trying to minimize
is the expectation
of the square of this temporal
difference error
so this is literally just the temporal
difference signal here where now my q
functions are parametrized by theta
and so the neural network is going to
use you know its algorithm stochastic
gradient ascent and back propagation to
optimize these parameters theta to give
me the best possible q function that
minimizes this td error this temporal
difference error
and again uh we think that there is a
strong evidence that that's what
biological learners are doing at least
at some level of their kind of
neurological hardware is minimizing this
this temporal difference error that we
talked about in the last lecture
so this is pretty cool you can actually
just take the update turn this into a
loss function and the neural network's
going to optimize those parameters theta
kind of for you and that's been a very
very powerful
approach
so you know we've seen this in
the deepmind atari video game playing so
this is one of my favorite examples of
block out you've seen this before if you
watch my channel
where essentially from this pixel space
a deep q learner with a convolutional
level layer
can learn
the right strategy the right quality
function for what actions to take uh
given
given what state it finds itself in and
it actually learns some pretty
interesting things that it should
actually eventually
drill a hole in one side here and then
it'll basically work itself out and
that's the most efficient way to
increase its reward
which is really cool that's that's why
they say human level control because
this this algorithm this deep q learner
is exploiting the physics of the game to
get solutions that only expert humans
would find
and so this is the architecture so it
has some convolutional layers some fully
connected layers
you know from pixel space to joystick
you know signal
but essentially this is just a big uh
kind of deep q learning demonstration
convolutional cue learning
and this is just the list of all of the
video games and i guess you know the
ones above the line it is better at or
better than human level and the ones
below the line it's still not as good
okay so
that was deep cue learning essentially
you can have
this this traditional q learning and you
can cook up a loss function for your
neural network that will essentially
through trial and error through
experience it will learn the weights
theta that give you the best q function
possible
and there's a variation of this that i
really like called
deep dueling q networks or dueling deep
q networks ddqn
which essentially
takes your quality function and it
actually splits it into two networks a
value network which is just a function
of the current state
and an advantage network which says what
is the advantage over just the value of
being in that state for taking an action
a
so this is a good
architecture
when you're the difference in in quality
for different actions is very subtle so
maybe i'm in a really good board
position in a game of chess
and the different actions i take are
giving me very marginal increases or
decreases of my quality function
and so what it does is it splits off the
value function of just being in a state
from the incremental advantage of taking
an action having been in that state
and i mean this is essentially
equivalent
to the q function it's just another way
of writing the q function
but now you can train two neural
networks and they're kind of dueling
with each other the value function is
trying to get as much
explanation of that q function just from
the state
and this advantage network a is trying
to figure out what the effect of taking
actions is and then you can kind of
optimize over these actions and do
interesting things
okay another really really important
concept in machine learning sorry
reinforcement learning is the actor
critic
learning and actor critic methods are
actually way older than deep
reinforcement learning so i'm going to
tell you what they are in general and
then i'll tell you how we use them for
neural networks
so the idea of an actor critic
reinforcement learner is essentially to
take the best of both worlds from
policy-based and value-based learning
so in the you know a few lectures ago we
talked about policy iteration and value
iteration and they have these kind of
different flavors and different benefits
and strengths
and so in an actor critic framework
we're going to have two um two learning
two learners an actor and a critic
and the actor is basically trying to
learn a good policy and the critic is
critiquing that policy based on its
estimate of the value
so the critic is learning a value
function essentially and the actor is
learning a policy
uh okay good so the actor is trying to
represent this policy pi and the the
critic is going to be uh using
information from its estimate of the
value function
and so one really really simple way to
do this is
remember that policy gradient algorithm
i was telling you about you can
essentially do an actor critic policy
gradient
where what you do is you're updating the
parameters of your policy uh so this is
policy update data
but you're using the temporal difference
signal from your value learner so your
value function is getting updated too
you're trying to learn this value
function from your critic and your
critic is essentially giving you the
error signal that you use to update your
policy
so again this kind of mixes the best of
both worlds you're using value
information but you're using that to
update a policy using this kind of
in some cases gradient policy
information
now in the context of deep neural
networks there's some interesting things
you can do
one of the ones i like is called this
advantage actor critic network
and it uses that uh
deep dueling queue network i told you
before where you split the quality
function into the value function plus
the advantage of taking an action
and so essentially now the actor again
is a deep policy network so this is a
deep neural network for the policy with
some weights theta
and then the critic is a deep dueling q
network uh q that tells you what's the
quality of being in a state and taking
an action
and so here similarly
this is that policy uh iteration that
policy gradient iteration i wrote down
earlier we derived earlier
except now this policy gradient
is updating the deep policy network and
and gradient iteration is much much
faster than
the model free techniques i was telling
you about in the last lecture using
gradient information will converge way
faster
than traditional q learning or
traditional value iteration
but it requires you have a model that's
parameterized by theta that you can take
the derivative with respect to theta
but remember in that deep policy
gradient
we needed our quality function
and so this again this is an actor
critic network because i'm doing policy
iteration a policy gradient iteration in
this case but i'm using a q network
for that quality function
so my q network is learning the quality
function and i'm updating my policy
using this policy gradient network
and presumably you update your your ddqn
the way you always do
by once you take actions and you get
rewards you'll update this this q
function using the temporal difference
error
so i think this is really cool you can
kind of mix
the best of a value-based formulation
and really q networks are kind of
value-based
and policy-based
you know for the optimization so you
optimize the policy using value-based
information
so this is really cool and this is
different than q-learning which is
purely value-based so in queue learning
you are still updating the q function
but you're updating the q function based
on q information and then at the end of
each optimization then you figure out
what your best policy is just by reading
it off
whereas here you're kind of jointly
you're optimizing the policy directly
but using this uh this cue information
this this value-based information
so this is kind of a neat a neat
approach
okay so that again was just the tip of
the iceberg of deep reinforcement
learning but we got a little bit more
specific into some of these methods so
very very popular deep quality function
networks
you can use those to do deep policy
gradients
for example in an actor critic so if you
like
you know there is an actor critic method
that uses a deep q network for the
critic to do a deep policy gradient uh
optimization
now you'll notice conspicuously here
there is this deep model predictive
control block that i didn't really talk
at all about it's kind of a different uh
a different flavor of optimization and
i'm almost certainly going to have a
whole video or series on deep model
predictive control later
but there's some really interesting work
in the community
where people are learning these kind of
really good optimal nonlinear
controllers using these these classic
dynamical systems optimizations like
model predictive control
but then they try to learn a policy that
mimics that that model predictive
controller so this can be a very
expensive online optimization it
requires a lot of model forecasting it's
very very
computationally intensive typically
and so if i do that expensive
computation maybe i'm teaching a
quadrotor how to fly through an obstacle
field
once i learn the right control actions
maybe i can embed that in a neural
network maybe i can train a policy that
very rapidly kind of encodes the
information of these deep model
predictive controllers
okay so that was again just a very high
level overview of some really important
topics building on some of the pieces
that we've been learning over the last
few lectures all right thank you